albert breer back here on the rich eisen
show from sports illustrated the mmqb
how are you albert
i'm good i'm good i'm sorry for my
tardiness you know what's going on
a little long do you get it my apologies
do you get a scoop is that what's going
on
uh yeah yeah no it was a productive
phone call it went a little longer than
i thought it was but we're good okay
very good what's your uh um overarching
impression of week one albert what do
you got for me
um you know and i i think bob this is
sort of like an abstract thing but i i
try to like think like of like big
league trends um you know after the
first week because i don't think
it's you know i don't think you should
be crowning anybody or indicting anybody
in week one and so the one thing that
really stuck out to me rich was
seeing the way patrick mahomes and tom
brady sort of
lifted their teams up and made it so
their teams didn't need to be perfect
and you know you think of the chiefs
getting off to the slow start falling
behind by double digits
you think of the bucks turning the ball
over you know god went dropping what i
think we we all expected to be a
touchdown pass fumbling inside the five
um you know in the fourth quarter
and how these guys had this great
ability to just kind of erase all of it
and
um you know in a roundabout way rich it
made me think about like what the rams
did this off season and what the niners
did this offseason the rams and niners
both had quarterbacks in their 20s
um both those teams had been to the
super bowl with those quarterbacks
and you know now both those quarterbacks
both those teams are moving off of those
quarterbacks and um you know it's
obviously happening more gradually in
san francisco than in los angeles but
the idea is the same
and i just think it's
i mean i like i know this is after one
week and everything else rich but
it's the i think it's from the
homesization of the nfl like i think
it's like we're at this place now at the
quarterback position where just being
good isn't good enough and i think you
can even connect it to like
the dolphins potentially moving off of
two of this quickly to going to get to
sean watson now who knows if that's
gonna happen six months from now maybe
it will maybe it won't but it's just i
think another example of the way people
are thinking differently at that
position
and i think part of it is
you know you're looking up at that
mountain you know what i mean and um you
know the rams had the number one defense
in the league last year and they go into
green bay and aaron rodgers hangs 32
points on them and they're out of the
playoffs right the niners you know who's
their head coach kyle shanahan and
what's his experience in the super bowl
well you know double-digit lead um in
the
fourth quarter with the niners and
mahomes made that not matter then three
years earlier where was he was the
falcons offensive coordinator in the
super bowl gets up 28 to three and brady
made that not matter and so i think like
that's sort of like an overarching
thought that i took away from um you
know week one was how we saw this
quarterback movement in the offseason we
saw teams that normally you wouldn't
think would be in the quarterback market
get in the quarterback market
and then i think brady and mahomes in a
certain way in week one
once again showed us why albert breer
here on the rich eisen show you just
mentioned about you know the watson
uh the swing at uh for the watson fences
that the dolphins stepped into batter's
box to mix metaphors and and took a
swing at um a couple of weeks before the
the regular season tour um and the
dolphins won in new england nobody's
sitting here and talking about what an
incredible performance tua had like
we're like we're talking about for say
jalen hurts of all people right or or
some of the rookie quarterbacks that we
saw even then they didn't win
nationally nobody's saying well two it
came out with that w what is going on
with that i mean like really put my ear
to the ground here and what you're
hearing about tua and miami and and
whether they really are all in despite
our colleague jeff darlington saying
that the the coach
uh gathered everyone together to say
this is our quarterback what is going on
there
albert i mean i think i think ryan
flores
is very well in tune with what his team
needs and i think there was a period
there where
he probably felt like this is just me
you know surmising yeah that the other
52 people in that locker room needed to
hear from the coach
that tua was their guy
um that said um i i can tell you that
the debate over who they should take
this overall
um a year and a half ago
was robust and i you know my
understanding was justin herbert had
some support in that room
and
look
they wouldn't be human if they wouldn't
like be looking at justin herbert and
thinking to themselves oh my god you
know what i mean like did we
did did we make a mistake here time will
tell whether or not that's the case
um you know but i i i do think they feel
pretty strongly and you know just
knowing some people who have connections
to that organization and everything else
like they feel pretty strongly after you
know three off seasons of building
behind brian flores the general manager
there chris greer like they've got a
team that's not only ready to get to the
playoffs but ready to win when they get
to the playoffs and
you know it kind of ties back to that
whole thing that i said is like you know
is your quarterback good enough and i
think there was a time in the league
when you could win with a little bit
less at that position if you really get
everywhere else
now it feels like if you're not really
good at that position then you need to
be perfect everywhere else and
you know i i think that that's going to
be a question going forward with tua is
is he good enough because i think a lot
of people in the nfl this isn't from
like in business like dolphins people
saying this to me but a lot of other
people who they get paid to evaluate
this stuff like you know like they watch
him at alabama and it's like well he's
instinctive and he's
like he plays fast and he's accurate and
then he gets on the nfl field last in an
nfl field last year and a lot of that
stuff just like looked sort of average
you know
and um so like i think the question
isn't whether or not tua can play right
now i think they know he can play right
now i think most people believe tua can
get you to the playoffs right now right
the question is can he elevate and can
he become
you know a top 10 type of quarterback
and if he can't get there
does that mean the dolphins are in the
sort of situation maybe the rams were
with jared goff you know where it's you
got to ask yourself some hard questions
they're already asking that question you
could understand why
if there's a guy who you know is 25
years old has five years left on his
quarterback and has already been a top
five quarterback deshawn watson you
would seriously look at something like
that albert breer here on the rich eisen
show uh what's going on with uh the
cowboys up front what can you tell me
about tank lawrence randy gregory big
game for the cowboys here in los angeles
against the chargers what do you know
about that
yeah so i i think like the you know
demarcus lawrence obviously like that's
a really unfortunate break for them and
he's had injuries in the past and i you
know i don't know if i'd relate to that
because there's a foot thing and it's
sort of a freak thing but he's going to
be gone for two months
and
that like to me uh
you know you just sort of look at how
patchwork they've been
and they'll get gregory back but like
like you know with randy gregory and
then over the years taking swings on
different guys like alden smith and and
and uh you know and if you want to go
further back greg hardy um and how
they've just sort of continually rolled
the dice to try and get those positions
right
um and lawrence was the one that they
really hit on
and now he's out for two months and you
know i think the cowboys defensively did
a lot of things well in the opener but
the fact is like such a big part of the
way that that defense worked and i works
i think dan quinn's a fantastic
defensive coordinator but a big part of
how the defense works you know the
seattle type of defense works is can you
get heat on the pastor and can you come
from multiple angles and hit the
quarterback
and demarcus florence is one of those
guys when he's at his best he changes
the math for everybody else he's going
to change the matchups he's going to get
more guys tickled up more guys are going
to be favorable spot favorable spot
because of him so now you take him out
of the equation and i think it's a big
big loss for the cowboys so you know dan
quinn's going to be earning his money
over the next couple of months you know
their hope is they get to get demarcus
lawrence back and you know for the
second half of the season and i like
yeah i think that there's you know
you know real reason to believe that's
going to happen but until then how do
you make it work and uh you know i think
it's a very real question it's a big big
loss for the cowboys few it's left with
albert breer the mmqb senior nfl
reporter here on the rich eisen show so
um the passing game in san francisco i
mean as if there's a nod enough question
marks about what kyle shanahan's
thinking and really meaning when he
talks about his quarterbacks jimmy g
gets the start but trey lance is the one
who throws the first touchdown pass of
the season and then of course it's
through he who he threw it to a kid that
hardly anybody's ever really heard of
and brandon ayook gets 0.0 like the full
blue tarsky for week one and and
yesterday's comment about how he needs
to be better than the guy behind him but
he's really hurt
what is going on with this offense in
san francisco albert
i mean i i think we're going to see you
know i i like i think we're going to see
some version of what we saw
um at quarterback um for the foreseeable
future for and i'm not saying past this
year of course it's eventually going to
become trey lance's show but for this
year as long as they're winning um i
think you're going to see a version of
what we saw on sunday which is you know
trey lance basically as a spot player um
i mean he's he's come a long way
but he had a long way to go and i and i
don't think he's ready to be the starter
at least you know in kyle's estimation
to this point what he wants in his
starting quarterback
um the good news is i think jimmy played
really really well on sunday and just
talking to him after the game you can
hear how comfortable he is and i think
there's almost like a frustration there
and that he's finally gotten to the
point where he feels like he's mastered
kyle's offense
and he's probably on the way out the
door you know after this year but that
said for this year i think it puts the
niners in a good spot
you know i also sort of wonder if
brendan naiuk is is where devo samuel
was last year where
you know
i think there's just sort of you know
different levels you get to in that
offense and it's uh it's it's an
intricate offensive plan for a receiver
kyle of course's background isn't
receivers he looks for very specific
things in receivers
you know and so you know i think there's
a next step that brian brandon iu has to
take and you know i think part of the
process here is them pushing him to get
there and i think most people would tell
you devos samuel took a step back last
year right i think that's fair rich that
bebo wasn't quite what everybody
expected him to be last year and then he
goes into year three and what happens he
explodes and so you know maybe it's
maybe it's just a part of the process
maybe things come together faster maybe
he can stay healthy uh better than bebo
could last year
um yeah but i do think that brandon iuke
is sort of in that process and so
i think you're referencing trent
sherfield who was excellent during camp
um and you know he was somebody ever all
those guys at the niners building were
talking about over the course of four or
five weeks of training camp i think what
trent sherfield has done is given them a
little flexibility where
if they need more developmental time for
brandon nyu and to bring him on try to
get him to the level debo samuel is at
now
they can do that because they think
they've got a veteran player who's
capable of filling a role for them all
right albert i appreciate the time and i
i i understand that you were on a call
very important call to start off i'm i'm
just wondering if you were doing that to
kill time so you wouldn't have to answer
the following question
uh which
which which program in the history of
the historical alliance
uh between the big ten and you know acc
and pac-12 actually won an
inter-conference game with a team in the
historic alliance which which program's
the first one to carry the mantle on
behalf of the big ten in that historic
alliance
well if we're talking about michigan
winning big games it must be september
rich
no no i i i i don't know if that's the
answer to the question well you kind of
answered it
it would be it would be your michigan
wolverine that's okay albert look we'll
we'll just
yeah yeah okay yeah richard which i will
say
our guys have a lot of work to do
your guys i mean to have a
the amount of coaching turnover that
they had like i thought beyond just the
win i'm being object yes i thought it
was a very nice win not just because i
don't think washington is very good but
like i think it was a nice one because
stylistically it looked a certain way
i thought they were very impressive in
the way that they played the way the
whole operation looked on saturday so
you can chalk that one up
another nice september win for the
wolverine oh my goodness gracious i'm i
chris i need oxygen because somebody
just took the high road here and i
wasn't expecting that i mean i'm getting
a little dizzy i might get the benz my
goodness okay very good the key word
there being september no i i know that i
i get it but just you know it's a one
week at a time business as you know
um in
you can't win in november and september
that's fair
albert thanks for the call brother you
be well we'll chat soon all right thanks
thanks for watching
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here